the crowds are back on the streets in
delhi
after seven weeks stores in one of
india's biggest markets southern bazaar
reopened on monday
traders say they could not be more
relieved
everybody of course is very happy
because at one
one part we were losing our livelihood
and also living in
the fear of coronavirus so definitely
each and every trader of the market is
very happy that finally
both things are on the better side
like many other indian states delhi
imposed a strict lockdown in april in an
attempt
to slow down a devastating second wave
of covet 19.
those restrictions have reduced the
number of new cases of the virus quite
considerably
but they've also meant a substantial
drop in people's incomes
the reopening in delhi is taking place
just a few days after the latest
economic figures showed india's gross
domestic product or gdp
dropped by 7.3 percent over the past
year its worst performance since records
began
70 years ago
more than 230 million indians have been
pushed into poverty in the past year
but migrant workers who lost their jobs
when lockdowns were imposed
are returning to the cities
the cases are not as high as they were
that's why we have come back
to earn money to feed ourselves there
aren't many ways to do that in the
villages
however as restrictions are eased state
leaders are preparing for a possible
third wave of the virus
as per their calculations we are
preparing for a peak of 37 000 cases a
day
we are calculating that if we reach this
peak how many beds and intensive care
units would be required
and out of them how much oxygen will be
needed and the number of medicines that
will be required
health experts say the most urgent task
for india is to get more people
vaccinated and while the government
addresses the shortage of doses it has
available
it's also being urged to make sure basic
covet 19 protocols including social
distancing and wearing masks
remain in place we need to ensure that
super spreader events
which have been the most dangerous
pathways
for the viral spread are strictly
avoided both through public resolve
as well as through administrative
vigilance
uh till possibly december this year
india's official death toll from the
pandemic is 350
000 though health experts say the actual
figure is likely to be
much higher as the country emerges from
what's widely described as the worst
crisis in its modern history health
experts say it's imperative the lessons
learned
are now applied elizabeth puranam al
jazeera new delhi